hey yo listen man we're gonna stand up
all right L Russell's in the building
ain't no normal [__] shout out to
Vallejo huh come on let's go man yeah we
here live with bootleg Kevin Splash to
Shante sieta you know
hey fan bases in different locations
sport mode I did it with no laces record
clean I did it with no cases my homies
ain't users abusers or rapist that's not
Flex that's just what a [__] see a s
ain't skill till he hit a rough SE want
to make a meal [__] go and get a tea
want to say the world tell them clone
another me started at noon I be done by
three I on 29 [__] check the DSP and
it's proud to pay pay themma pay me must
be a mirage my God it can't be 20
pushups then I'm out for the day hit my
mama crib I just live up the way I hit
up harami take me to O need a little
break I'm in a for a Day California King
smoking in the California king off the
block hard to stop I'm big as y'all mean
too piece spicy dipped and bow Bean
whatever I say going to sound like to
extra extra read all about me did it in
a year can't believe y'all without doubt
me [__] so sick they pay and Dr fousy
go and sell a bit my bad if I'm grouchy
if I'm in my a is South V not South
Beach flow water she I got a mouth leak
a through gold in my mouthpiece GC on
the gold in my mouthpiece time after
time I had to prove myself a [__]
really BW I had to cool myself shed hair
shed weight out grew myself if I owe
anyone I had to sue myself fan bases in
different locations sport mode I did it
with no La record clean I did it with no
cases my homies ain't users abusers or
rapist huh God
damn they can't say that line God that's
when [__] going to get
silent and the streams real and the
following real and the growth real and
the life real [__] hey appreciate you
guys watching this freestyle we got
another one coming and then another one
and then another one and they're all
brought to you by our good Folks at LRG
clothing you already know what it is LRG
been keeping you fly for years they got
so much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30% off L-R -
g.com another freestyles on the way
presented by LRG